damage is still being assessed this
morning from harvey late last night
president trump tweeted that he signed a
disaster proclamation freeing up federal
assistance for the state of texas david
begno is a short distance from rockport
where the storm made landfall david good
morning we're on the road to rockport
texas but we've tried for the last two
hours to get there and there are power
lines on the roadway there's storm surge
that's pushing water onto the roadway
and we're having a really hard time
getting there in fact we followed we
tried to follow emergency crews into the
area but they were having to dodge all
kinds of debris in the roadway there is
a pretty significant flooding on the
side of the roadway in ditches as we
went through the town of taft there is
heavy destruction but no cell phone
reception so the only area where we were
going to be able to to broadcast was
here we literally pulled over on the
side of the road rockport by the way is
where the roof of the senior housing
complex collapsed last night
initially rescue crews said we can't
even get to those people who are trapped
video inside the eyewall of hurricane
harvey shows the power of a category 4
as it barreled into the gulf coast last
night several areas looked like disaster
zones
wind gusts of over 160 miles per hour
and flooding rains slammed towns along
the water it's not expected to let up
for days
rockport and fulton were some of the
city's hardest hit they are the first
populated areas to see a direct impact
early views of the damage show several
mobile homes flipped or already in
pieces a gas station sign lies flat on
the ground after it was toppled people
staying at this hotel had to be
evacuated to a nearby school debris
everywhere roof's totally gone
rooms exposed
harvey is no joke as you enter the
bedrooms of the hotel you see the outer
walls and windows are gone
parts of this area high school were left
unrecognizable after it was demolished
by the destructive winds
just to the south of brockport in
aransas pass the police department
posted this video showing the walls of
their building blown off
this reporter in corpus christi was
nearly lifted off the ground as the
winds picked him up during harvey's
landfall
this storm is the first category 4
hurricane to hit the texas gulf coast
since hurricane carla which came ashore
not too far from here 56 years ago
so again we're about 12 miles outside of
rockport and people are already starting
to get out and look around there's
significant damage if you look in the
distance it looks like a roof has been
torn off of a building the side the
facade of this structure
has been blown off but again
driving around here is what's really
treacherous and you can tell with the
winds it's pretty strong the storm i
would say is probably 30 miles inland
from where we are but we're still
feeling wind gusts of up to 45 and 50
miles per hour as the rain continues to
come down and this storm is going to
continue to be a rainmaker for the next
48 to 72 hours
we can see that wind there david david
begno and taft texas thank you